but i think they don't they don't  realize the power of the choices that  they make behind them because they still  because we've been conditioned in such a  way that we're most women not most men  but some women feel they they feel fall  into that category feeling victimized  well it's because women like to be  victims yeah and i i think that's and i  think i think a lot of people like to be  victims because i think most people  don't like taking responsibility for  themselves but look at it like that  like look at it like this but the thing  is the thing is men aren't bailed out  women are always bailed out of a bad  decision they're homeless there's  women's shelters there's no men's  shelters not not  by and large